Netflix has already renewed You for a fourth
season and after the devastating Season 3 finale,
we've got a ton of theories about
what comes next for Joe Goldberg.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and in
this video I'll be discussing the best theories
and predictions for Season 4 and beyond,
and what the chances are that Joe's crimes
will finally catch up with him.
Spoilers and speculation ahead,
of course, so take care.
The Season 3 finale ends with
Joe fleeing the US for France.
However, there's a little clue in
the final scene that hints it might not be as
easy as Joe expects to escape the attention of
his fellow countrymen, when he overhears two
Americans in the Parisian café talking about
how so many New Yorkers have left the city.
I think this is a big tease that we'll get to
see some characters connected to Joe's old life in
the Big Apple crossing paths with him in Paris.
First of all, there's Ethan, Joe's
colleague from Mooney's bookstore,
his girlfriend Blythe, Beck's friends Annika
and Lynn, and there's the Salinger family who
we know from Peach owned an apartment there.
Cousin Inez finally vacated the Paris flat.
The Salingers also had a P.I. investigating
the circumstances of Peach's death who
interviewed Joe in New York because
they suspected some kind of foul play.
Karen Minty, Joe's ex-girlfriend, also said
she wanted to visit the French capital when
Paco was talking about where in the world
he'd like to go if he could go anywhere.
I would go to Paris.
Any of these people would
surely recognise Joe if they came across him,
and I wouldn't put it past him murdering any of
them or at least locking them up in a new cage
or basement to stop his secret getting out.
A character who's likely to come back
into Joe's life is Ellie who had to flee
LA to get away from the Quinns after her sister
Delilah's murder at the end of Season 2.
From the Sarasota postmark on the
postcard that Joe received from her,
she appeared to have gone to Florida.
And in Season 3, Joe mentions that he's
still secretly sending her money
to keep her off the Quinns' radar.
I send the profits to Ellie.
Now, something to remember is that
Ellie only knows Joe by his pseudonym Will, so
she doesn't know his real name is Joe Goldberg.
However, Ellie is pretty smart and savvy so I
think she would get suspicious when she hears
news reports about Love Quinn killing Joe
Goldberg and pictures start appearing of the
apparently dead man she knows as Will,
and if Joe keeps sending her money,
I'm sure she'll figure out there's something
iffy about what happened in Madre Linda.
So I wouldn't be surprised if she'd
started investigating things.
She may even work out some details of Joe's
murderous past in New York, because she was
after all involved in the script rewrite of
Forty's planned adaptation of Beck's book.
During the crazy events of that night,
Forty figured out that Dr Nicky was
actually innocent and that Beck's
ex-boyfriend was the real killer.
He murdered her in a jealous
rage, and he framed Dr Nicky.
How much of this epiphany
did Forty share with Ellie?
We don't yet know, but I suspect we may
find out in Season 4 or a future season.
I killed Henderson, and I
don't feel guilty about it.
Leave a thumbs-up if you'd
like to see Ellie return!
In the Season 3 finale, we
see Joe has a new alias, Nick,
which could be a nod to Dr Nicky who he framed
for Beck's murder in the Season 1 finale.
And I think we're still not done with Dr Nicky's
storyline in the series because the way Joe plants
a box with Natalie's teeth to ensure Love
is blamed for the carnage in Madre Linda
is uncannily similar to the suggestion
Beck had for framing Dr Nicky in her book.
There's this part where I talk about a box of
mementos that I found on Nicky's property.
A jar of teeth.
What if someone on
the "Free Dr Nicky" subreddit reads details
about Love Quinn's supposed murder-suicide
and connects it with what happened to Dr Nicky?
And they figure out that it was really Joe behind
the fatal stabbing of Ryan Goodwin and now
he's pinned that murder on his dead wife.
Also, what about the Salinger family
P.I. who didn't believe what he read
in Beck's book that Dr Nicky was guilty?
Maybe not everyone was completely convinced.
Although Dr Nicky told Forty he didn't
want to get involved in looking into Joe..
If he killed Beck..
there's no telling what this man is capable of.
He'll be punished, but not by us.
Trust in divine justice.
..perhaps he'll decide he's had enough now of
being the fall guy for Joe's crimes in New York
and will get someone to go after him, something
Joe worried about briefly in Season 2.
This is bad, Love.
Plainclothes cop?
Dr Nicky.
What's he got on me?
Joe's also in Paris, of course, because
he's searching for Marienne who fled after
Love revealed he'd been lying to her
and had killed her ex-husband Ryan.
Though we don't know for sure yet that
Marienne's in France, it's certainly
plausible as she told Joe she was born in Paris
and would go there to get away from her ex.
Joe wonders at the end of Season 3 whether
he'll be able to win Marienne back and
convince her that Love's warnings were wrong.
However, I think Marienne understands now just
how toxic Joe is as she already suspected it.
Something in me knew that it was
too good to be true.
So I don't think she'll
delude herself that he's a good guy in a bad
situation as Joe frequently tells himself.
After all, she'll likely have seen the same news
stories as everyone else about what happened,
including Love's murder-suicide note and reports
about DNA evidence showing Joe died in the fire.
So, if he suddenly turned up on her doorstep now,
he wouldn't exactly look innocent, would he?!
Assuming that Marienne rejects Joe when he finds
her, it'll be interesting to see how he reacts.
And there's a possible hint in Season 2.
In the end, our guy has to
murder all three women.
It's like the ultimate irony.
That was from Forty's screenplay "Bang Marry
Kill" and it could be some deep foreshadowing
of Joe's fate, as he's already killed two of
the main women in his life, Beck and Love.
Alternately, and perhaps optimistically,
might Joe remember what he really thought
about the ending of Forty's screenplay?
That it sounds like the most
anti-feminist horror film in history.
And, if so, could he stop himself this
time and find a way to let Marienne go?
Or perhaps Marienne herself will find a way to
put a permanent end to Joe's stalking days.
Theo could also return in Season 4 because he's
got concrete video evidence that Joe was involved
in his stepmother's murder as he uncovered
camera footage of him driving Natalie's car
away on the day she disappeared.
Theo may initially assume,
like everyone else, that Joe is dead;
however, there'll surely be traces of
Joe moving around Madre Linda on the night
of his supposed death on various cameras,
from either doorbell cams or street cameras
recording him escaping his burning house.
Although Love was responsible for Theo's
injuries, he was infatuated with her.
I love you.
And if he suspects or figures out that Joe killed
her, he might start looking to make him pay.
It's interesting that as part of the story
Joe crafted when he faked his own
murder and Love's suicide, he decided
to portray her as what he called
The Mrs Lovett of Madre Linda
by putting a piece of his own toe into
a pie before burning the house down.
In the musical version of the Sweeney Todd
story, the serial-killing barber burns Mrs
Lovett alive but then her young assistant
Tobias who's very attached to her gets revenge
for her murder by killing Todd.
Another person who might have dirt
on Joe is Love's mother Dottie.
We know the Quinn family shut down
any investigation into Henderson's death
and they covered up Love's murder of the
au pair years earlier, so it's reasonable
that Dottie might know where the bodies of
Love's other victims are buried.
And what if she figures out that
Joe might still be out there and was
responsible for her daughter's death?
Although her financial assets aren't what
they used to be, she could still find a
way to frame Joe for any of Love's crimes.
There was also a cryptic moment in the second
season when Dottie implied that the Quinns already
had knowledge of some of Joe's dark secrets.
Your secrets are safe with us.
It's also entirely possible that
Love herself had some kind of revenge planned
for Joe in the event of her untimely death.
What did you do with her body?
Or Delilah's?
I told you.
I took care of it.
What if Love has set up a way for Joe to get
the blame for Candace and Delilah's deaths
in the event of her premature demise?
Perhaps the location of their bodies
together with evidence that could
incriminate Joe will come to light?
A kind of posthumous revenge for pinning
everything that happened in Madre Linda on her,
including the death of Ryan which Joe
carried out by himself, of course.
Now, this next theory is a little
crazy, but let's briefly entertain
the possibility that Love is still alive.
Could she, like Joe, have taken an antidote
before being injected with aconite, so
that after he left the burning house,
she too was able to get out of there?
If so, she'd have to lay low as everyone's
seen her fake confession to the
murders of Natalie and Ryan.
I don't think this theory is very plausible
as it'd diminish the Season 3 ending.
However, crazier things have happened on TV
so, I wouldn't discard it entirely if the
writers wanted to introduce a huge twist in
Season 4 or later where Love suddenly bursts
back into Joe's life seeking revenge.
What I think is much more likely though
is that we'll see Love return in Season 4
as part of a hallucination that Joe has,
similar to the one he had of Beck in Season
2 or the one Love had of Forty this season.
And I break down Love's death and the
shocking finale in a lot more detail
in my Season 3 ending explained video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, do you have any theories
or predictions for Season 4?
And do you think Joe will eventually get caught?
If so, how?
Comment with all
your ideas below and if you enjoyed this, then
a like and a share are hugely appreciated.
You can tap left for my full You playlist
where I'll be adding my next video with
the easter eggs you missed in Season 3
or tap right for my ending explained.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!